Бути енергоефективним – це те саме, що бути соціально відповідальним.
Вперше в історії будівництва технологія і будинок, який повністю може бути автономним
і використовувати лише сонячну енергію для абсолютно всіх потреб.
Навіть меблі у цьому будинку, вони також розумні,
і в усі полички вбудовані системи підзарядки телефону.
Якщо ви кладете телефон, він автоматично заряджається.
Основна мета функціонування усіх систем в цьому будинку, розумних систем –
це енергозбереження.
Багато хто мріє про те, щоб бути незалежним і вільним.
І наша компанія:  я, Максим Гербут, і «Haus.me»
виготовляють перші у світі повністю автономні мобільні будинки.
[Ukraїner
Зелена експедиція]
[Спільно з green cubator]
[Наддніпрянщина
Київ]
Cтандарт пасивних будинків був винайдений в інституті пасивних будинків
в  Дармштадті, в Німеччині 1995 року.
Вдалих прикладів пасивного будівництва дуже багато в Європі –
це вже набагато більше 30 тисячі будинків, і це зразок найвищого рівня будівництва.
Різниця цього будинку від інших в тому, що він надзвичайно енергоефективний.
Він може бути повністю автономним, незалежним від зовнішніх енергомереж,
водопостачання, газопостачання, електропостачання.
Тут 24 інженерні системи.
Він потребує в 10-20 разів менше енергії ніж звичайні будинки.
Тут немає заліза, бетону, пінопласту, деревини.
Будинок побудований з композитного матеріалу.
Цей будинок оснащений складною системою контролю температури всередині.
І цей будинок може вирішувати, що потрібно включити або переключити через те,
скільки людей є всередині, яка температура назовні, який клімат назовні,
які побажання людини, що тут живе.
За мікроклімат і за якість повітря в цьому будинку відповідає тепловий насос,
який може давати в 3-5 разів більше теплової енергії аніж використовує електричну енергію.
Всі системи можуть бути керовані дистанційно.
З будь-якої точки планети можна керувати
будь-якою системою.
Завдяки системі рециркуляції води в душі
цей будинок може економити до 80%.
Також є вбудовані меблі і цей будинок облаштований усім необхідним для того,
щоб тут комфортно жити.
Будинки «Haus.me» поставляються клієнтам повністю готовими, зібраними для життя.
Людина може починати там комфортно жити через годину після доставки.
[Наддніпрянщина]
[Вишгород]
Наша компанія складається з двох частин – це основний офіс у Сієтлі, у штаті Вашингтон, у США
і конструкторський відділ тут в Україні, в Києві.
В нашій компанії зараз, в різні часи працювало до 15 чоловік –
це інженери, це маркетологи і фінансисти.
Це наш виконавчий директор, Сергій Тичина, людина, що відповідає за те,
як усе відбувається в нашому
гаражі-департаменті в Україні.
Цей будинок виробляється за власною технологією, з композитних матеріалів.
Ззовні будинок укритий склопластиком – це матеріал, який стійкий до атмосферних впливів,
він не боїться ультрафіолету, не руйнується.
Тобто цю поверхню і цей колір не потрібно заново перефарбовувати буде. Ніколи!
Зовнішнє покриття будинку – це склопластик, це скловолокно.
Воно міцне на розрив і гнучке водночас, хоча це скло.
Воно просочене поліефірними смолами так,
що формується каркас, здатний витримувати навантаження.
Ось це панелька товщиною 12 міліметрів покрита шаром завтовшки 3-4 міліметри склопластику,
і вона легко витримує навантаження ваги здорової людини.
Ця поверхня не підтримує горіння.
Каркас будинку також виготовляється із склопластику.
Можу продемонструвати елемент каркасу  –
це композитний склопластиковий профіль.
Він міцніший за сталь, проте дуже легкий.
Хай вас не лякає, що це склопластик: він не б'ється!
Загальний час складання одного будинку: близько місяця.
Тому є можливість виготовляти декілька будинків паралельно.
Тобто планова мінімальна виробнича потужність: 5 будинків на місяць.
Абсолютно всі системи, сам будинок на 100% спроєктовано у 3D.
Частина цих компонентів: 28, якщо бути точним, у цьому будинку виготовлені на 3D принтері.
Кожний компонент цього будинку прорахований на міцність,
і загалом це технологія, за якою проєктують яхти і літаки.
Я завжди дуже захоплювався фізикою і будівельними технологіями, інноваціями,
і я великий фанат енергоефективних систем і пасивних будинків.
Я і моя команда, ми завжди відвідували дуже багато виставок, інноваційних заходів.
Це те, чим ми живемо, це не щось нове, це те, що ми робимо кожного дня.
Моя компанія – це моя сім'я.
Я їх поважаю, люблю як членів своєї родини. Багато хто з них працює зі мною вже 20 років.
Юрій керує процесом збірки, виготовлення наших будинків,
і він працює в нашій компанії і зі мною вже більше 17-ти років.
Юрій саме та людина, що знає кожний маленький гвинтик у цьому будинку.
Ми адаптуємо наш будинок і конструктив нашого будинку під збірку людьми,
які зовсім необізнані в будівництві, але по маркуванню, по отворам,
по позиціюванню деталей, неможливо буде схибити.
Наприклад, як ці написи на фанерному покритті: вони вказують, де який листок має бути,
і фрезерування  ось цих спеціальних ступеней,
вони не дадуть вам не той листок фанери не туди прикрутити.
Написи для проводки і по довжині кабелю, і по маркуванню ви не зможете схибити.
Ви просто не зможете не той кабель не туди протягнути.
Оразу, якщо ви купите цей продукт і будете його збирати, у вас нічого не вийде.
Вам треба трошки почитати, подивитися класифікацію і потім... як меблі.
Ми заповнили аплікацію і неочікувано отримали грант від ЄБРР.
Ми навіть були запрошені і були фіналістами конкурсу два роки тому,
і наша команда літала в Лондон, в центральний офіс ЄБРР,
як один із найкращих інноваційних проєктів Європи.
Всі компоненти, з яких складається цей будинок,
виготовляються за нашою ліцензією і кресленнями.
Наразі наша компанія має близько
40 виробничих партерів по всьому світу,
які виготовляють для нас компоненти для зібрання цього дому.
Наприклад, склопакети ми виготовляємо зі скла, виробленого в Великобританії.
Якісь фрагменти з дерева виготовляються в Україні,
декоративні матеріали виготовляються в Італії, інженерні системи, рекуператори в Німеччині.
Більшість пластику і композитних матеріалів виготовляється в Сполучених штатах.
І ми адаптуємо деякі компоненти до того місця, де ми виготовляємо будинок.
І надаємо можливість збирати ці будинки за нашою технологією, за нашою ліцензією будь-де,
з мінімальними інвестиціями.
Ми можемо розвернути виробництва таке ,як Ви бачите тут, за місяць.
А розвиток нашої компанії – це дуже просто.
Ми плануємо зробити інших людей такими  божевільними, як ми,
навіть від цієї ідеї, від цього концепту.
І у нас, здається, виходить!
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерки
Каріна Пілюгіна, Наталія Вишинська]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Режисерка монтажу
Ліза Літвіненко]
[Оператори
Михайло Шелест, Марія Теребус]
[Інтерв'юерка
Оксана Кузема]
[Субтитрувальник
Михайло Маршалок]
[Ukraїner]
[Спільно з green cubator]
[Створено за підтримки проєкту «Кліматичні Інноваційні Ваучери»,
що фінансується ЄБРР та ЄС]